Tout en continuant, et ne vous inquiétez pas,
quand je suis arrivé dans ces tribus, je ne me suis pas peint en jaune
et je n'ai pas couru avec lances et pagnes.
Mais j'ai en effet trouvé des gens qui appartenait quelque part,
et ils m'ont inspiré, ces gens extraordinaires,
et j'aimerais vous présenter quelques-uns de mes héros.
Ce sont les Huli.
Les Huli sont parmi les gens les plus extraordinairement beaux
de la planète.
Ils sont fiers et vivent dans les hautes terres de Papouasie-Nouvelle-Guinée.
Ils ne sont plus nombreux, et ils sont appelés les hommes à perruques.
De telles images, voici ce que tout ça signifie pour moi.
Vous avez passé des semaines, des mois à parler avec eux,
je veux les mettre sur un piédestal et j'ai dit :
« Vous avez quelque chose que beaucoup de gens n'ont pas vu.
Vous siégez dans cette nature sublime. »
C'est vraiment ce à quoi ils ressemblent.
C'est la vérité.
Vous savez pourquoi ils sont fiers, pourquoi ils sont comme ça,
pourquoi je me suis vraiment cassé le dos
pour les prendre en photo et vous les présenter ?
C'est parce qu'ils ont ces rituels extraordinaires.
Les Huli ont ce rituel : lorsqu'ils sont adolescents,
pour devenir un homme, ils doivent se raser la tête,
et ils passent le reste de leur vie à se raser la tête chaque jour.
Ce qu'ils font avec ces cheveux,
ils en font une création,
une création très personnelle.
C'est leur création. C'est leur création Huli.
Ils sont appelés les hommes à perruques Huli.
C'est une perruque sur sa tête.
Elle est entièrement faite de cheveux humains.
Puis ils la décorent avec les plumes des oiseaux de paradis,
et rassurez-vous, il y a beaucoup d'oiseaux.
Très peu de personnes vivent là, donc pas de quoi être contrarié.
Ils passent le restant de leur vie à récréer ces chapeaux,
et aller de plus en plus loin, et c'est extraordinaire.
Il y a un autre groupe, les Kalam, ils vivent dans la vallée d'à côté,
mais parlent une langue très différente et ont l'air très différents.
IIs portent un chapeau fait avec des scarabées,
ces fantastiques petits scarabées vert émeraude.
Parfois, un chapeau contient 5 000 ou 6 000 scarabées.
Ils passent leur vie entière à collecter ces scarabées
pour faire ces chapeaux.
Les Huli m'ont inspiré avec leur sens d'appartenance.
Peut-être dois-je travailler plus dur à trouver un rituel qui m'importe
et revisiter mon passé pour voir quel est mon rôle.
Une partie très importante de ce projet
a été la manière dont je prends en photo ces gens extraordinaires.
Au fond, c'est la beauté. Je crois que la beauté est importante.
Nous passons toute notre existence centrés sur la beauté :
de beaux endroits, de belles choses, et finalement, de belles personnes.
C'est très, très, très significatif.
J'ai passé toute ma vie à analyser de quoi j'ai l'air ?
Est-ce que je suis perçu comme beau ?
Est-ce que ça importe si je suis beau,
ou est-ce purement basé sur mon esthétique ?
Puis je suis parvenu à une conclusion très étroite.
Dois-je traverser le monde en photographiant, excusez-moi,
des femmes entre 25 et 30 ans ?
Est-ce ce que la beauté va devenir ?
Est-ce que tout ce qui vient avant et après est sans importance ?
Ce n'est que lorsque je suis parti en voyage,
un voyage qui était si extrême
que j'en ai encore la chair de poule quand j'y pense.
Je suis allé quelque part,
et je ne sais pas si quelqu'un a déjà entendu parler de Chukotka.
Est-ce que quelqu'un en a déjà entendu parler ?
Chukotka est, techniquement, aussi loin que l'on puisse aller
et être toujours sur une planète vivante.
C'est à treize heures d'avion de Moscou.
Il faut d'abord se rendre à Moscou, puis c'est un vol non-stop de 13h,
si vous arrivez à destination.
Comme vous le voyez, certains ratent l'atterrissage.
Puis, lorsque vous atterrissez, à Chukotka vivent les Chukchis.
Les Chukchis sont les derniers indigènes inuits de Sibérie.
J'avais entendu parler d'eux, je n'avais jamais vu de photos,
mais je savais qu'ils étaient là.
J'étais en contact avec ce guide et il a dit :
« Il y a cette tribu fantastique. Ils ne sont que 40.
Ça ira. On va les trouver. » Nous sommes donc partis.
Lorsque nous sommes arrivés, après un mois de voyage sur la glace,
je n'étais pas autorisé à les prendre en photo.
Ils disaient : « Vous ne pouvez pas nous prendre en photo.
Vous devez attendre de nous connaître et de nous comprendre.
Vous devez attendre jusqu'à ce que vous voyez comment nous agissons. »
C'est ainsi, des semaines plus tard, que j'ai vu du respect.
Ils n'avaient aucun jugement.
Ils s'observaient, des jeunes, des personnes d'âge moyen aux vieux.
Ils ont besoin les uns des autres, les enfants doivent mâcher la viande
parce que les adultes n'ont pas de dents.
Et les enfants amènent les personnes âgées
aux toilettes parce qu'ils sont infirmes.
Il y a cette communauté fantastique de respect.
Ils s'adorent et s'admirent les uns les autres.
Ils m'ont vraiment appris ce qu'était la beauté.
(Applaudissements)
Je vais demander un peu d'interaction avec le public.
C'est très important pour la fin de ma discussion.
Si vous pouviez regarder quelqu'un à gauche et à droite,
je veux que vous les observiez et que vous leur fassiez un compliment.
C'est très important.
Ce pourrait être leur nez, leur chapeau, ou même leur aura, peu importe,
mais s'il vous plaît, regardez-vous, faites un compliment.
Soyez rapides, parce que je n'ai plus beaucoup de temps.
Et il faut que vous vous en rappeliez.
Bon, merci, merci, merci, vous vous êtes fait des compliments.
Rappelez-vous bien de ce compliment. Rappelez-vous en pour plus tard.
Une dernière chose, c'était très profond, ça s'est passé il y a juste deux semaines.
Il y a deux semaines, je suis retourné chez les Himba.
Les Himba vivent au nord de la Namibie, à la frontière de l'Angola.
J'y avais déjà été auparavant et j'étais revenu pour présenter mon livre,
pour leur montrer les photos, engager une discussion, pour dire :
« C'est ainsi que je vous ai vus, que je vous aime et que je vous respecte.
Qu'en pensez-vous ? Ai-je raison ou tort ? »
Je voulais ce débat. C'est très, très, très émouvant.
Une nuit, nous étions assis autour du feu de camp,
et je dois être honnête, j'avais un peu trop bu,
j'étais assis sous les étoiles pensant :
« Vous avez vu mes photos,
nous nous aimons les uns les autres. » (Rires)
Et je suis un petit peu lent, j'ai regardé autour de moi et j'ai dit :
je pense, peut-être, que la clôture a disparu.
N'y avait-il pas une clôture la dernière fois ?
Vous savez, cette grosse clôture de protection autour du village.
Ils m'ont regardé et ont dit : « Ouais, chef est mort. »
Et j'ai pensé, le chef est mort, d'accord,
regarde les étoiles, regarde le feu de camp.
Le chef est mort. Qu'est-ce que le chef est mort a à voir avec la clôture ?
« Le chef est mort.
D'abord on détruit, d'accord ? Puis on réfléchit.
Puis on reconstruit. Puis on respecte. »
Et j'ai éclaté en sanglots, parce que mon père venait juste de mourir,
avant ce voyage,
et je ne l'avais même pas reconnu,
je ne lui avais jamais été reconnaissant pour le fait que je suis ici aujourd'hui
grâce à lui.
Ces gens m'ont appris que nous ne sommes qui nous sommes
que grâce à nos parents, nos grands-parents, et nos ancêtres
remontant aussi loin que possible,
et moi, peu importe à quel point je suis romantique ou idéaliste,
je ne savais pas ça il y a encore deux semaines.
Je ne savais pas ça il y a encore deux semaines.
Alors qu'est-ce que ça veut dire, tout ça ?
J'aimerais vous montrer une image, c'est une image assez spéciale,
et ce n'était pas celle que je voulais choisir.
J'étais assis là l'autre jour, et je dois finir sur une image forte.
On m'a dit : « Montre-leur la photo des Nenets. Les Nenets. »
Mais ce n'est pas mon image préférée.
Elle a dit : « Non non non. C'est une photo incroyable.
Vous êtes dans ses yeux. »
J'ai dit : « Qu'est-ce que vous voulez dire par là ? »
Elle a répondu : « Non, regardez de plus près. Vous êtes dans ses yeux. »
Lorsque vous regardez la photo de près, on voit mon reflet dans ses yeux,
donc il a, peut-être, mon esprit et je suis dans son esprit,
et alors que ces photos vous regardent, je vous demande de les regarder.
Vous ne serez peut-être pas reflétés dans ses yeux,
mais il y a quelque chose de follement important chez ces gens.
Je n'ai pas les réponses, ainsi que je l'ai partagé avec vous,
Mais il doit y avoir quelque chose.
Si vous pouviez réfléchir brièvement à ce dont j'ai parlé
sur la beauté et sur l'appartenance, et sur nos ancêtres et nos racines,
et j'ai besoin que vous vous leviez tous pour moi, s'il vous plaît.
(Rires)
Vous n'avez aucune excuse. Il est presque midi.
Ce n'est pas une ovation, rassurez-vous,
je ne suis pas à la pêche aux compliments.
On vous a fait un compliment il y a quelques minutes.
Je veux que vous vous teniez droit.
Je veux que vous inspiriez. Voici ce que je dis.
Je ne vais pas me mettre à genoux, ni vous demander de porter une chèvre,
et je sais que vous n'avez pas de chameaux.
La photographie est tellement puissante.
C'est un langage que nous comprenons tous maintenant.
Nous le comprenons vraiment,
et nous avons ce feu de camp numérique mondial, non ?
Je veux vous partager avec le monde, parce que vous êtes aussi une tribu.
Vous êtes la tribu TED, non ? Mais rappelez-vous ce compliment.
Tenez-vous droit, inspirez par le nez,
et je vais vous prendre en photo, d'accord ?
Je dois faire un panoramique, ça prend une minute donc concentrez-vous.
Inspirez, tenez-vous droit, ne riez pas. Chhh, inspirez par le nez.
Je vais faire une photo.
(Appuie sur le déclencheur)
Merci.
(Applaudissements)